you had a meeting about what you're not
going to do in the following year versus
what you're going to do and all the
plans
how did a conversation go so so I just
said every quarter I meet with my Golden
Sex guy he flies in me and my wife we go
we sit there and we talk about how the
markets down what's going on I had
dinner last week with David Solomon I'm
sorry Miami your Goldman Sachs guy what
do you mean he's my advisor he's my
financial advisor yeah so and we're
having dinner last week so we're looking
at what's going to happen in 2023 and
we're sitting there going through all
the projects that we have going on how
the consulting firm is doing how do
insurance companies doing how the media
companies doing how connect our
technology companies doing we're looking
at everything and then then we have to
look at what are we taking off the table
so hey speaking gigs couple hundred
thousand dollars an hour to go speak
here well maybe this year we're only
going to do it if we're only going to
the following opportunities because
that's going to help with this and
that's a you know relationship that's
going to lead to this and it's going to
match the calendar because these are the
three months you're available to do this
versus let's take this out let's take
that out so the mindset becomes more
about not having a to-do list but do not
do lists like I am no longer gonna do
this I am no longer gonna do that and
that frees up time to put more into we
had a meeting a month ago and I sat down
with uh our leaders here and I said I
don't want to go wide right now I just
want to go deep we have way too many
companies and projects that we're
managing that we keep adding another one
and another one and another one I want
to take these things here and go hire
the right leaders and Executives to take
it deeper and deeper and deeper let's
strengthen these companies and then
increase valuation and then possibly
consider this but we're not at a point
right now to go more we have
I think it's nine companies we're
operating right now and uh they're all
doing good a couple of them are doing
great and uh you know we need we need to
be more focused in the next 12 months
I'd like to hire somewhere around six to
ten c-suite Executives 200 000 plus
range salary bonuses to find the right
leaders because you know from the
outside like this week my schedule this
week's been a insane schedule this week
the December I had a meeting this week
with the board they flew in then the
next day we had all the major insurance
companies I work with we bring them in
we enter you know entertain them take
them to Prime Steakhouse and then the
next day I'm you know having a you know
message with them on what we're doing
for 2023 what went good bad ugly in 2022
what things were concerned about what's
going on with the state of the union of
insurance industry with ourselves then
the following day I had four masterminds
here with our insurance Executives each
of them was hosted uh by a different
executive and one group had 40 people
out I want to spoke to those guys for
two hours and I had a two hour break
went to the next one spoke for two and a
half hours then I went to the next one
at a different location two hours then I
went to the last one spoke there for two
and a half hours and then I stayed with
those guys and we played Spades all
night till three o'clock in the morning
because I was being punked by these guys
from New Orleans Memphis Chicago
thinking just because I'm Middle Eastern
I don't know how to play space and we
showed them we know how to split Place
page and then the next day which was
last night I brought the top guys 100
people with their spouses we put a party
at the house last night we wrapped up at
12 30 Sunday night and then I'm back at
it again this morning so it's it's a lot
of intentional thinking of what is going
to deserve our attention this year and
what we need to
set aside and then get a little bit more
disciplined by bringing the right
support so it gives us more time to give
attention to those things that are
growing do you consider the things
that's going on in the world in this
decision like 100 a lot of people that
we're seeing like the layoffs and like
people are quitting their job but you're
saying I need to hire more people how do
we start making those decisions even
though it might be a good a good
business model like this is good but
maybe not for this season
well no first of all only you know how
much money you got in the bank only you
know how hard you work only you know how
hard you want to work this only you know
you know like we can sit in front of the
camera and act hard and then but we know
last time we talked to our wife and we
said hey babe I kind of want to tone it
down 50 and I want to spend more time on
this I want to travel 60 less these are
the conversations right I know what I'm
saying in that conversation and I want
that conversation to match my behavior
so if I have a 20-year revision
Tied by another 20 years after that and
I'm willing to play offense aggressively
right now this is not a time to play
defense this is a time to play offense
and you can play offense if you've made
the right choices the last five years 10
years if the last five years you were
planning on becoming a Deca millionaire
because Bitcoin was going to go to a
quarter million dollars well then you
took a hit if you were planning on
becoming a millionaire because you
thought a handful of nfts you thought
the land you were going to sell for 5.2
million and you bought it for 10 grand
well then you took a risk because the
get rich quick type of models man that
takes a lot of people out but you know
if your philosophy is a real philosophy
Builds on data growth real substance
versus just pure luck I'm hoping to get
rich there's a lot of crypto
millionaires right now that are Uber
drivers there's a lot of nft
millionaires that are right now
Uber drivers I like uh I remember being
21 years old I'd gotten out of the army
and I'm down to my last penny so but I
got my credit cards and being all these
other things I got my credit cards and
I'm sick and tired of it but I'm a I'm a
big Gambler at that time I'm going to
Vegas I'm playing poker I'm doing all
this stuff and I have 49k in debt I said
I know I'm gonna pay it off I go take
all the money out of my credit cards
I go with a handful of my friends and
they know who they are Freddie a bunch
of these guys we get in the Expedition
we go to Vegas this is the big plan this
is the big plan I take 25 000 and I said
boom I'm gonna start with I'm gonna play
whatever thousand dollar hand if I lose
I play two thousand dollar hand if I
lose I play four thousand dollar hand if
I lose I play eight thousand other hand
well there's no way in the world I'm
gonna lose like you know whatever the
number was that I had calculated I'm not
gonna lose 12 hands in a row wow I lost
12 hands so I lose all my money so then
I come back I'm gonna dip 49k I was the
guy the uh crypto millionaire that is
now driving Uber I was that guy so I hit
rock bottom girl Finance all this stuff
happens I'm sitting there saying you
know I'm gonna go back into the army
because that's the easy way you know
flight fight Freeze um flights I'm like
I'm going to the Army that's what I'm
gonna do I'm not the freeze guy I'm just
going to go back I know what to do with
the Army I'll do 20 years they're gonna
pay off my debt I have a nice four
thousand dollars I'll go become a cop or
firefight afterwards I'm probably going
to be married maybe two or three times
because you're in the military you don't
get married once I got a few kids I'll
get the benefits and I'm good how old
are you at this point 21. 21 years old
so I come out and I'm like
yeah I can't you can't constantly run
away from problems your habits suck your
mindset sucks
you're trying to look for a quick way of
doing this this thing takes work so I
came back I started creating a
discipline of uh uh reading books
learning about Finance economy then I
worked on Morgan Stanley Dean would have
gotten to finance I said I want to be in
the financial industry for 20 years my
20 years came up last year 2021 makes it
20 years I'm in financial industry now
for 21 years so then wealth was created
so if
everything you're doing right now for
the most part is intentional then you're
intentionally growing hiring today if
you were winging it being hopeful that
you're making the right choices then
you're in a scary place today
[Music]